bienvenue dans le débat sur France 24 j
- 3 avant le coup d'envoi de la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar il ne faut pas politiser
le sport à déclarer Emmanuel Macron lors
de son discours au sommet de la paix à
Bangkok cette Coupe du Monde suscite de
nombreuses controverse sur l'impact sur
l'environnement sur les conditions de
travail des travailleurs immigrés qui
ont construit les stades ou encore sur
le traitement réservé aux femmes et aux
lgbt+, l'équipe de France est arrivée
hier sur place à Doha le capitaine de
l'équipe Hugo Lloris a refusé de porter
le brassard en faveur de l'inclusion
contrairement au capitaine de
l'Allemagne et de l'Angleterre bref la
controverse suscité par le choix du
Qatar comme pays organisateur c'était il
y a 12 ans et elle continue et bien on
va y revenir ce soir y a-t-il un malaise
finalement dans cette Coupe du Monde au
Qatar faut-il la boycotter le foot
est-ce aussi de la politique et bien on
va débattre avec mes invités j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés parce
qu'elle Boniface bonsoir directeur de
l'iris et puis une réédition de votre
livre la géopolitique 50 fiches
d'actualité passionnant évidemment
surtout les grands thèmes de
géopolitique merci d'être avec nous en
face de vous nous avons Nathalie Godard
bonsoir directrice de l'action Amnesty
internationale France bienvenue à vous
Annie Gasnier est avec nous journaliste
RFI productrice de l'émission radio foot
internationale et puis également vous
présenter le Café des Sports chaque
semaine sur France 24 la prochaine
émission c'est demain bonsoir Annie et
bienvenue pierre Stéphane Ford bonsoir
vous êtes journaliste réalisateur du
documentaire cathare 2022 un scandale
français et c'était diffusé sur France 2
dans le cadre de l'émission Complément
d'enquête et c'était en collaboration
avec la cellule investigation de Radio
France bienvenue à vous avant de
démarrer ce débat on va écouter Emmanuel
Macron c'est donc un extrait de son
discours à l'Apec puis on va écouter
également la ministre des Sports Amélie
Odea Castéra c'était ce matin sur France
Inter
je pense qu'il faut pas politiser le
sport et la vocation d'abord ces
questions là il faut se déposer quand on
attribue les événements c'est quand on
attribue des jeux qui souhaitent des
Coupes du Monde ou des Jeux Olympiques
qui font en toute honnêteté c'est poser
la question et que la question soit
climatique ou qu'elle soit des droits de
l'homme il faut pas se les poser à
chaque fois que l'événement est là
c'est au moment où l'attribue qu'on doit
se la poser un boycotta du tout
d'ailleurs pas plus qu'aucun de nos
partenaires moi je serai au
Qatar en effet si l'équipe avance bien
absolument supporter de la première
minute jusqu'à la dernière minute de
l'ensemble de l'art match que d'ailleurs
j'irai voir avec les clubs avec des
licenciés sur le terrain en France pour
centre sentir justement le cœur des
Français qui qui bat derrière cette
équipe de France je pense qu'on a
vraiment besoin là maintenant de
communiquer cette énergie positive et de
vivre cette ce bonheur de la Coupe du
Monde ce bonheur du sport la négation
qui couvrez justement le sport depuis si
longtemps est-ce que c'est différent
cette année est-ce que vous sentez un
malaise oui par rapport aux gens qui
vont suivre la Coupe du monde sans doute
qui se demandent pas vraiment s'ils vont
regarder les les matchs peut-être mais
dans quel état finalement va se dérouler
la compétition c'est à dire qu'est-ce
que le Qatar il y en a beaucoup qui
découvrent il y en a beaucoup qui
aussi le contexte et le problème qui est
posé
au foot ça fait 12 ans qu'on en parle ça
fait 12 ans que le Qatar a été désigné
ça fait 12 ans que le soir où on avait
su que c'était le Qatar on s'est dit
mais c'est la pire des candidatures déjà
on parlait de stade avec de l'air
conditionné on parlait de la chaleur on
parlait du désert on parlait de ces
stades qui n'existaient pas donc c'est
pas véritablement une découverte et
c'est peut-être là qui est aussi le
malaise mais à trois jours justement de
cette couverture est-ce que ça douche un
peu votre enthousiasme non peut-être pas
dans l'émission mais pour les passionnés
de football mais en tout cas on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il y a une coupe du
monde qui va démarrer je crois que ça
oui mais c'est aussi par le fait que ce
n'est pas durant les vacances d'été mais
c'est durant l'hiver et que les gens
beaucoup de gens qui l'ont obtenu
d'ailleurs non ce déplacement de l'été à
l'hiver bien sûr pour pas qu'il fasse
trop chaud et que peut-être qu'on ne
mette pas trop d'air conditionné mais
surtout les gens vont se disent mais
quand est-ce qu'on va regarder les
matchs quoi parce que beaucoup ne seront
pas en vacances et notamment les enfants
donc ça reste quand même particulier
malaise pierre Stéphane fort ce malaise
vous vous le décrivez dans votre
reportage ou dénoncez carrément un
scandale français la France n'aurait pas
dû soutenir le Qatar en tout cas cette
coupe du monde elle est éminemment
politique puisque c'est Nicolas Sarkozy
qui a apporté son soutien au Qatar alors
président de la République pour qu'ils
obtiennent cette coupe du monde donc il
a un petit peu difficile aujourd'hui de
décorer les la Coupe du Monde et la
politique puisque c'est peut-être la
Coupe du monde la plus politique qui se
soit tenue
vous êtes d'accord parce que Boniface
c'est très politique toute façon une
coupe du monde ou pas en faveur du Qatar
c'est platiny qui a voté en faveur du
Qatar et là où on l'a peut-être un
désaccord je ne pense pas qu'il est obéi
à des instructions données par Nicolas
Sarkozy mais la voile platiny a été
déterminante effectivement il a changé
d'avis tout de même après
selon lui etc et avec un objectif très
simple qu'il a d'ailleurs mis c'est que
le football doit aller partout il y a
une sorte de volonté de conquête du
monde par le football et après avoir été
en Amérique sous les critiques après
avoir été en Asie sous les critiques
après étaient en Afrique sous les
critiques il va au Qatar alors c'est
vrai là je vous l'accorde que le Maroc
est plus un pays de football que le
Qatar le Maroc était pas candidat mais
je reconnais qu'il y a beaucoup de
questions qui se posent que
d'habitude il y a nous enfin il y en a
un peu avant la Russie alors ce type
d'émission faut-il y aller où l'on sait
finalement quand c'est pas dans un pays
occidental et c'est même il y a des gens
dans les productions ils veulent
boycotter les coups du monde les JO
parce qu'ils n'aiment pas le sport mais
là disons que à la fois parce que le
Qatar est vraiment un pays très
particulier d'une part et d'autre part
parce qu'il y a plus de médias il y a
plus de réseaux sociaux il y a plus
d'enquêtes il y avait moins d'enquêtes
auparavant votre documentaire vous
n'avez pas pu le faire 20 ans auparavant
sur un pays et beaucoup plus donc
logique a changé mais je pense aussi
qu'il faut être conscient de quelque
chose c'est que c'est aussi un malaise
occidental c'est que là aussi comme pour
la guerre en Ukraine il y a the West
versus the reste et en Amérique latine
en Asie en Afrique on se pose pas la
musique de question et je pense qu'il y
a les occidentales et il y a un malaise
français dont vos documentaires rend
bien compte d'ailleurs parce que les
liens particuliers et très particulier
qui existe entre le Qatar et la France
suscite la curiosité l'inquiétude pour
certains et suscite donc beaucoup plus
de focalisation que pour un autre pays
vous êtes d'accord vous pouvez répondre
à passer je pense que le mal c'est aussi
qu'on se rend compte que le Qatar
maîtrise extrêmement bien sa
communication à investi des centaines de
millions de dollars dans la
communication et chaque enquête
journalistique chaque enquête des ONG
sur le terrain mais en lumière la
réalité crue du terrain très différente
de la communication que peut faire
passer le kata et ça je pense que ça
suscite aussi le malaise chez le public
effectivement ce hiatus entre un soft
power effectivement très bien méprisé et
maîtriser de la part du Qatar et puis ce
qui se passe donc sur le terrain à
amnister international vous dénoncer les
atteintes aux droits humains le système
de kafala en l'occurrence ce système de
parrainage et puis l'exploitation donc
de tous ces travailleurs par les mêmes
de travail forcé j'ai lu un chiffre dans
de gardiennes je crois pas que ce soit
le vôtre mais disons que 6500 ouvriers
venus d'Inde du Pakistan du Népal et du
Bangladesh et du Sri Lanka sont morts
pendant la construction des stades alors
je sais pas si vous soutenez ce type de
chiffre en tout cas vous vous demandez
une indemnisation de la part de la FIFA
c'est ça un peu votre combat aujourd'hui
oui effectivement nous depuis le début
on a documenté l'impact de cette
décision d'attribution de la Coupe du
monde
maximum de kafala par le système de des
agences de recrutement qui faisaient
payer les travailleurs pour pouvoir être
embauché donc un système illégal au
Qatar par les problèmes de d'absence de
salaire minimum etc et en fait le Qatar
a pris progressivement certains de
décisions on a pris en compte donc c'est
c'est plein des ONG on a réformé en
l'occurrence ce système de cafards à
partir de 2017 il y a eu un certain
nombre de régulations qui sont qui sont
apparus assez progressives puisque le
système de Falla il y a eu plusieurs
décisions successives qui l'ont amené à
la réformer jusqu'à 2020 mais ce qu'on
constate nous dans les enquêtes qu'on
fait sur le terrain c'est que
effectivement ça n'est pas le cas
c'est-à-dire que le système de cafalaï a
toujours c'est toujours en place que il
y a toujours des conditions de travail
qui sont indignes y compris pour des
systèmes de si pour les conditions de
pour les parents les compagnies de
sécurité qui sont embauchés par les qui
sont embauchés par les par les équipes
donc aujourd'hui le contenu n'est pas
sur la réalité des changements il peut y
avoir eu des des changements de
législation qu'on la salué mais la
réalité des changements pour les
travailleurs migrants ça pour le coup ça
n'est pas en place d'exécution derrière
parce qu'elle Bonita c'est difficile de
faire l'impasse ou même pour moi
nationale hier matin sur ce thème il y
avait avec moi le représentant de
l'orientation du travail que vous
connaissez très certainement et qui dit
que l'agitation a changé et que
effectivement ça changement
d'administration n'est pas toujours
appliqué parfois de la part d'autorité
qatary de priver mais aussi
d'entreprises étrangères et que le
problème c'est qu'il ferait plus de
contrôle sur l'application de la
nouvelle législation mais donc il y a eu
un pas en avant on peut dire mais il y a
deux choses un il s'élève contre le
chiffre de 6500 morts que tout le monde
reprend alors qu'il n'est pas de pensée
extrêmement bien document tu es quand
même ce chiffre j'ai rencontré Peet de
Pattinson le journal Les huarden qui a
fait cette enquête il m'a montré les
registres d'ambassade sur lesquels il
s'est basé et le nombre de de népalais
de Sri Lanka qui sont morts
c'est sur 10 ans et l'ensemble des
étrangers vivants Qatar et ça devient
dans le débat les morts pour la Coupe du
monde du monde c'est pas tout à fait la
même chose
si je peux terminer vous répondre
que je termine la phrase bon du coup je
suis coupé c'est une bonne technique je
reconnais
mais oui mais un débat on laisse parler
l'autre normalement enfin c'est surtout
qu'on se revendique de la démocratie et
donc ce chiffre n'est pas documenté et
il est sur une période beaucoup plus
long qu'on le reprend en étant seulement
attribué au chantier de la Coupe du
Monde et l'autre ce que reconnaît l'eau
it qui est pas une organisme procata
c'est que oui il y a encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire et moi je soutiens
Amnesty dans la lutte que vous faites
pour obtenir le fond d'indemnisation
mais que au final la Coupe du Monde a
servi de levier a servi de coût de
projecteur pour que les choses ne
restent pas comme cela de faire pression
finalement sur le bio
c'est pas demain qui aurait une Gay
Pride au Qatar on est d'accord c'est pas
demain que les immigrés seront traités
de la même façon que les nationaux on
est d'accord mais selon l'OIT je me
réfugie derrière eux il y a une
évolution suffisante faut continuer faut
pas faire en sorte qu'après la Coupe du
monde tout le monde soit oublié et que
on revienne aux dérives votre
documentaire a permis quand même de
faire prendre conscience de certaines
choses la Fédération Française a du coup
changé la société de gardiennage après
votre commentaire etc donc il faut je
veux dire il faut alors il y a une façon
de faire à moitié plein ou à moitié vide
est-ce que les choses n'ont pas changé
et qu'elles sont toujours dramatiques ou
en fait en réalité du fait de la Coupe
du Monde on parle plus du Qatar on parle
moins les autres pays de la région alors
que la kafala ça existe au Liban ça
existe en Jordanie on en parle pas
allez-y justement pierre Stéphane fort
juste donner ses précisions sur le
gardien sur ce chiffre qu'on comprenne
bien non mais le chiffre ce qui me
paraît intéressant avec ce chiffre c'est
qu'il a été mal interprété beaucoup ont
dit 6500 morts sur la construction des
stades c'est faux factuellement parce
que c'est ce qui avait écrit dans
l'article ce qui est juste en revanche
c'est que ces 6500 morts a priori selon
l'enquête du Guardian pit Pattinson j'ai
rencontré il a l'air extrêmement sérieux
il m'a montré ses sources 6500 morts sur
l'ensemble des chantiers qui permettent
à la Coupe du monde le nom de cette
manière c'est à dire les infrastructures
aéroports métro route hôtel et stade
voilà a priori c'est plutôt ça la
réalité de cette information
c'est pas parce qu'il y a la Coupe du
monde qu'il y a une amélioration parce
qu'il y a la Coupe du Monde qui a des
constructions d'infrastructures qui
causent ces
fractions c'est violation de droits
humains et il y a des changements parce
qu'il y a des campagnes d'organisation
comme Amnesty et d'autres campagnes
il y a une campagne parce que on
constate qu'il y a des conséquences très
graves de ces activités pour les
personnes pour les droits humains pour
le climat par ailleurs etc que c'est pas
toute la région on en parle moins non
non ne donnons pas l'impression que ce
serait une très bonne chose attribué la
Coupe du monde à des pays où il y a
plein de où il y a des violations des
droits humains et que c'est ça qui
feraient avancer c'est ces pays-là non
je je m'en doute c'est pour ça que je
rectifie il faudrait effectivement on va
revenir justement sur la façon dont sont
attribués à ces Coupe du Monde Annie
Gasnier l'autre scandale c'est celui le
scandale écologique dont tout le monde
parle effectivement les stades
climatisés les allers-retours des fans
qui ne peuvent pas rester sur place donc
ça fait beaucoup d'avions par rapport
aux autres coupes du monde c'est
vraiment le cas il y a un scandale
écologique ou pas moi je me souviens
avoir suivi la Coupe du monde au Brésil
et le Brésil est un pays immense qui
fait 17 fois la France il y avait des
stades à peu près partout par exemple le
Cameroun était basé au nord de Rio dans
la ville de vittolia et jouer à Manaus
donc là aussi il y avait des
allers-retours il jouait abrasellia les
les équipes se baladaient sur tout le
territoire donc c'est vrai aussi que
l'attribution là en l'occurrence alors
les supporters vont voyager mais
beaucoup moins les équipes donc je pense
que en fait c'est peut-être la FIFA
qu'il faudrait plus accuser que le Qatar
parce que le Qatar il se retrouve à être
le l'organisateur et le pays haute de la
compétition mais qui se sont battus pour
j'imagine enfin plus que battu oui mais
c'est vrai que la FIFA attribué et d'une
manière nos confrères de France Football
l'avaient montré dès après il y avait
une grande enquête sur comment a été
attribué cette compétition alors on
parlait tout à l'heure de Platini et des
gens qui auraient voté pour mais c'est
vrai que la FIFA c'est toujours assez
obscur actuellement on entend Janine
Fantino on a su aujourd'hui qu'il sera
le seul candidat à sa réélection en mars
prochain en 2023 et lui il parle déjà de
l'Arabie Saoudite pour la Coupe du Monde
de 2030 donc il y a aussi des questions
qu'on peut se poser autour de la grande
entreprise au-dessus du pays haute qui
est la FIFA faut rappeler que la FIFA en
tant qu'entreprise commerciale doit à un
certain nombre de principes par ailleurs
un certain nombre de principes directeur
des Nations Unies à respecter c'est à
dire que elle doit appliquer une digence
raisonnable sur le respect des droits
humains dans l'ensemble des activités
qui sont en lien avec son entreprise
donc aujourd'hui nous on demande c'est
pour ça qu'on demande à la FIFA de
mettre en place un fond de la
démonisation pour les travailleurs
migrants et leurs familles il va y avoir
un fonds
de la FIFA enfin vous amener c'est
internationale me semble-t-il le 14 est
opposé le ministre des Sports pour
l'instant a dit concentre-nous sur le
football et il n'a pas du tout donné
suite à cette demande ni la FIFA dizaine
d'ailleurs la Fédération française de
football qui n'a pas non plus qui n'est
pas non plus engagé
par exemple vont participer à fond c'est
un autre chose ça n'est pas la même
chose c'est les bleus et c'est pas la
FFF c'est-à-dire c'est l'équipe de
France qui a fait une déclaration disant
qu'ils étaient sensibles la question de
droits humains et que ils allaient
abonder sur un fond qui était différent
nous ce qu'on a demandé à la FFF c'est
de prendre position publiquement pour
soutenir le fond d'indemnisation à
hauteur de au moins 440 millions de
dollars qui est qui correspond à ce qui
sera aux primes remise au 32 équipes qui
vont partir qui vont participer à la
compétition et pour l'instant la FFF n'a
pas pris c'est pas engagé publiquement
ni clairement et a dit bon on verra ça
plus tard et la FIFA a dit
concentrons-nous sur le football donc on
dit quoi
ça c'est clair il est
ultra conservateur effectivement il va
être élu par acclamation parce que il a
fait une campagne un très clientélisme
etc en Afrique notamment sur le
continent
puisse pas être candidat donc il a
vraiment là une partie du problème parce
qu'elle Boniface justement c'était
facile
une partie problème c'est que le vote
était pas publié et que finalement
chacun a ce qu'il veut que Platini était
le seul à dire pour qui il a voté
contrairement aux autres il y a eu un
vote publique pour 2026 il y a
maintenant on a changé avant c'était 24
membres du comité exécutif qui votaient
dans le plus grand secret ce qui est pas
normal aujourd'hui c'est une fédération
une voix sauf que pour 2026 Donald Trump
s'est bien ancienne en dit ceux qui
votent pas pour moi vont être
sanctionnés par les États-Unis et donc
vous allez les pays qui n'ont pas voté
pour le Maroc de peur de sanctions
américaines ce qui a pas suicider
beaucoup de protestations à l'époque et
même Infantino normalement il aurait dû
partir cheval enfin vraiment de façon
très fugueuse pour condamner ça c'est
jamais fait toutes les histoires et
pourquoi parce que toute l'histoire de
la Coupe du Monde il y a toujours
beaucoup de clientélisme quel que soit
les les Coupe du Monde on essaye de
cher ami on donne des aides etc il y a
de la politique donc il faut dire bien
sûr politique
c'est la première fois qu'il y a des
menaces de sanctions sur des votes de la
part du président d'un pays contre les
pays qui ne vaudrait pas en faveur et
normalement selon la RM et la FIFA les
pays n'ont pas le droit d'interférer
dans les affaires de la Fédération là on
voit que certains pays ont quand même
demandé leur fédération de voter pour
les États-Unis sans que Infantino ne
réagissent le problème tout de même
on peut peut-être la comprendre à l'aune
de la Coupe du Monde 2022 parce qu'en
fait c'était les États-Unis qui devaient
gagner la Coupe du Monde 2022 en fait il
y avait une selon oui mais j'ai plus le
documenter dans le reportage j'ai
rencontré de nombreux compagnons de
route de Michel Platini qui m'ont
expliqué le deal en gros qui était mise
en place par Seb la terre président de
la FIFA et Michel Platini président de
l'UEFA Russie 2018 États-Unis 2022 et ça
c'était bordé c'est-à-dire que Michel
Platini c'était engagé avec une île
Gulati représentant du football
américain il s'était
évidemment le deal était fait et puis
est intervenu le déjeuner à l'Elysée et
puis Michel Platini a changé d'avis donc
les Etats a obtenu la Coupe du Monde pas
par une voix d'avance non pas par une
par 4 oui
il a beaucoup d'influence puisque
c'était le patron de l'UEFA et les
autres membres de l'UEFA le suivait et
ça c'est extrêmement bien documenté dans
dans l'enquête judiciaire que j'ai pu
lire puisque le même phénomène s'est
reproduit pour l'Euro de foot 2016 c'est
à dire que Michel Platini a entraîné les
votes de l'UEFA pour la France
c'est autre chose difficile de dire que
le football n'a rien à voir avec la
politique ça c'est impossible depuis le
départ la première Coupe du monde elle
est géopolitique sans Uruguay parce que
l'Uruguay veut exister par rapport au
Brésil et l'Argentine je vois pas
l'Italie en 34 etc tout le temps
effectivement quand on l'a fait au
Mexique c'est pour reconnaître
l'émergence de ce pays à chaque fois
c'est on ne peut pas dire que c'est que
le football n'est pas politique il est
bien sûr donc alors qu'est-ce qui est
politique c'est toujours est-ce qu'on va
au bout justement des choix politiques
est-ce que on parle de l'universalité
des droits de l'homme parce que c'est
aussi politique enfin c'est ça c'est le
problème à partir au moment où il y a
des liens entre les deux bien sûr il
faut parler des droits de l'homme etc et
en même temps c'est là où c'est un peu
délicat on ne peut pas organiser les
compétitions que dans les pays
occidentaux et par ailleurs disons que
amnésie fait un boulot formidable de
documentation des violations des droits
de l'homme mais il y a pas c'est pas
nécessaire qui désigne cela il y a pas
un comité démocratique qui désigne le
pays de la Coupe du monde donc le
résultat c'est qu'il faut que le
football aille partout et que on s'en
serbe quand il y a une compétition pour
obtenir des résultats et que le coût de
projecteur qui est dédié sur le pays
l'oblige à modifier ce qui est le plus
gênant
aussi parce qu'il y a de plus en plus de
gigantisme dans l'organisation de ces de
ses compétitions la Coupe du monde là
est avec 32 équipes ce qui est déjà
beaucoup celle de 2026 sera avec 48
équipes et on voit ça avec la
compétition continentale de africaine
c'est à dire avec la canne ou maintenant
il y a 24 équipes ça a été décidé à un
moment où finalement le pays qui s'était
vu attribuer la compétition qui était le
Cameroun tout d'un coup on lui a dit ça
passe de à 24 équipes alors qu'avant
c'était 16 ça veut dire plus
d'installations ça veut dire plus
d'infrastructures et plus de travaux
donc plus d'argent gigantisme qui fait
qu'il y a de moins en moins de pays qui
sont candidats ou qui veulent être
candidats parce que ça coûte très cher
bien sûr et donc finalement sur les pays
du Golfe qui se peuvent se permettre de
financer parce que par exemple le CIO a
changé ses règles et maintenant les
l'argent de compte pas en mai 40
milliards comme Pékin ça marchera plus
le les paris 2024 c'est 7 milliards il y
a quand même alors ce que vous dites
c'est vrai pour les jeudis
malgré l'inflation donc effectivement il
y a des pays où il y a déjà en fait
aussi au départ la première Coupe du
Monde c'est que 13 pays il y a des pays
qui veulent pas y aller il y a pas
beaucoup de pays qui jouent au football
maintenant vous avez deux sens
fédérations tout le monde veut aller de
l'ampleur en fait ce qui veut dire que
ça ne suffit pas de Nathalie Godard
c'est bon j'avais compris que ce qui
veut dire qu'il ne suffira pas de faire
les déclarations comme la FIFA le dit
pour dire que des critères droits
humains seront pris en compte approché à
attribution c'est pas suffisant c'est
pour ça qu'on a du mal à croire à la
sincérité des engagements de la FIFA
dans la matière parce que vous parlez de
mon évoque l'Arabie Saoudite enfin
l'Arabie Saoudite c'est on est au-delà
du Qatar en matière de record de
réception des droits humains qui vient
d'être désigné quand même pour organiser
les Jeux asiatiques donc divers donc on
est bien d'accord que la question de
l'organisation d'événement sportif et on
a dénoncé nous ce qui s'est passé pour
Pékin précédemment en Afrique du Sud à
Rio etc on a travaillé sur on a
travaillé que sur le Qatar on a
travaillé sur énormément de différentes
compétitions sur le lien avec la
question du droit humain les activités
sportives ne sont pas être détachées de
ces questions politiques et des
questions de droits humains et donc si
on veut respecter les droits humains
peut-être qu'il faut se poser la
question de de la de la du format de ces
organismes de ses compétitions pour que
ce soit possible de respecter les droits
humains dans dans leur dans la
préparation de ces compétitions quelle
que soit le pays
à l'universalisme de la compétition on
peut avoir beaucoup d'équipes et
demander à ce que les droits humains
soient respectés et justement sur
l'autre débat notamment je pense qu'on
va y venir sur le climat sur la pression
du climat il y a des gens qui vont dire
on peut plus rien de compétition
sportive parce que ça atteint le climat
et c'est quand même toujours un peu le
sport qui est la variable d'ajustement
des demandes pour cela et on demande pas
que les droits humains soient respectés
pour les manifestations culturelles on
ne demande pas que les bons donc on
demande quand même que dans un pays où
il n'y a aucun stade que le fait de
d'attribuer la Coupe du monde ne donne
pas lieu à la construction de l'ensemble
de ces stades avec toutes les toutes les
condamnations toutes les parties où les
violations des droits humains qui vont
avec le dire ça c'était pas ça c'était
ça a été c'est lié aux infrastructures
de la Coupe du monde donc on est vrai on
n'est pas c'est pas la situation de un
pays où il y a une niveau de violation
de droits humains qui est précédent et
où il y a les stades ont déjà été
construits nous on a fait des stades qui
ont été construits pour la Coupe du
monde donc vraiment il y a des questions
à se poser sur tout ce processus se
souvenir de la Coupe du Monde de 1978
c'était en pleine dictature en Argentine
il y avait eu là aussi des appels au
boycott là aussi il y avait eu beaucoup
de critiques et malgré tout pendant
cette compétition on a aussi jamais
autant parlé des violations des droits
de l'homme de la Torse c'est une caisse
de résonance voilà qui se passait à
quelques mètres du stade de la finale
dans la fameuse ezma l'école de la
marine donc ça avait aussi porté un coup
de projecteur sur ce qui se passait les
maires de la Place de Mai avaient été
beaucoup filmé toi à ce moment là donc
ça peut aussi parfois aider à progresser
ou à
dénonceros qui étaient l'organisation de
luth armée contre Videla avait appelé
disons NON venez et rendez compte de la
dictature rendez compte de cela vider là
était passé inaperçu parce qu'il y a eu
Pinochet on a beaucoup parlé de Pinochet
vider la rive trois ans plus tard il
sait pas tellement remarqué et en 78
finalement bon alors en même temps ça
lui a servi de façon interne pour
asseoir son pouvoir mais sur le niveau
international il a été extrêmement
l'équipe de France en tout cas on le
sait est arrivé hier à Doha est le
capitaine de l'équipe Hugo Lloris a
refusé là aussi on parle de droit humain
mais cette fois LGBT de porter ce
brassard en faveur de l'inclusion
contrairement au capitaine de
l'Allemagne et de l'Angleterre il l'a
justifiait en disant qu'il ne souhaitait
pas manquer de respect au pays
organisateur on va l'écouter
en France lorsqu'on accueille des
étrangers on a souvent
l'envie qui se prête à nos règles qui
respecte notre culture
et j'en ferai de même lorsque j'ai au
Qatar tout simplement donc après je peux
être d'accord ou pas d'accord avec leurs
idées mais
je dois montrer du respect par rapport à
ça Nathalie Godard quand vous entendez
ça respect des traditions il viendra en
France ils respecterait les nôtres alors
il faut savoir que les personnes LG au
Qatar sont passibles de Satan
emprisonnement on n'est pas dans une
vague tradition on est dans autre chose
je veux dire on peut pas se cacher
derrière relativisme culturel pour pour
dire qu'on n'est pas les joueurs c'est
ça aussi les gestion les joueurs les
joueurs ont à partir du moment où ils
ont c'est des personnes qui ont de
l'influence sur les sur l'opinion ils
peuvent apporter des messages positifs
je peuvent à défaut de s'engager il
pourrait ne pas dire que que qu'il faut
appliquer un certain relativisme
culturelles sur la question des LGBT
dire nous ce qu'on demande on a demandé
aux joueurs depuis le début de s'engager
parce qu'on sait que c'est la pression
des joueurs et de la fédération et des
équipes qui peut changer des choses les
joueurs de l'équipe d'Australie par
exemple voilà qui serait virale
et qui est devenu viral et on voit que
ça peut effectivement apporter du
changement donc ça c'est quand même très
intéressant de voir que ce levier existe
Annie Gasnier
peuvent obtenir des changements parce
que il y a aussi c'est comment on fait
passer le message et la la crainte
toujours c'est d'apparaître comme des
donneurs de leçons ce que veut dire ou
Glory ça à mon avis c'est que il veut
pas revend quelque chose il va rester
discret sur le sujet c'est tout c'est
pas par exemple ce fameux brassard alors
que d'autres joueurs le portent Raphaël
c'est une façon de revendiquer quelque
chose il veut ne pas prendre position
sur le sujet c'est tout peut-être que la
question aussi c'est de savoir si les
joueurs de l'équipe de France peuvent
prendre position en fait ils veulent le
veulent le peuple
position ils vont pas être viré parce
qu'ils ont pris position
mais en tout cas le poids du Qatar dans
l'économie française et en particulier
dans l'économie du foot français il est
indéniable quoi je veux dire les droits
TV du championnat de France sont
valorisés grâce à la présence des qatari
au PSG on va revenir justement sur le
Qatar
mais pour terminer sur les LGBT sur
l'implication ou pas l'engagement ou pas
des joueurs moi je pense qu'ils sont
dans la droite ligne de la Fédération
Française c'est-à-dire que la Fédération
Française n'a pas véritablement
préposition Noël le Grete est très
discret sur le sujet on sait justement
le poids que peut avoir le Paris
Saint-Germain dans le championnat de
France avec toutes les stars qui
défilent depuis quelques années donc
finalement je pense que le profil bas de
la fédération se reflète dans la
position du capitaine de ce qu'ils
doivent s'engager les joueurs chacun
personnel
peut-être plus à titre personnel c'est
vrai que quand il a voulu faire changer
par exemple les contrats sur avoir un
droit de regard sur les contrats de
sponsoring enfin ceux qui soutiennent
l'équipe de France il a obtenu 15 causes
en même temps on croit savoir que tout
le monde était pas sur la même longueur
d'onde donc c'est difficile aussi dans
un collectif il y a des joueurs très
jeunes peut-être que ils ont pas encore
finalement pris conscience de l'impact
qui peuvent avoir parfois tout tous ne
sont pas mbappés alors c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant de revenir sur le
Qatar parce qu'à Boniface pourquoi
est-ce que ça intéresse autant le Qatar
le foot c'est le soft power
sur la carte parce que en 95 et 1000
locataires en Angleterre le loyer du
Séoul Qatar maintenant puis personne
pose la question et donc on sait où est
le Qatar donc c'est aussi face à un
outil de soft pas ouais c'est pas la
première compétition qu'ils organisent
parce que il y a une compétition
mondiale de handball il y a eu des
couilles c'est une résonance quand même
pour l'athlétisme compétition mondiale
il y a pas eu d'appel au boycott parce
que le foot
donc on voit que le foot a une
importance tout à fait particulière et
différente et donc le Qatar estime que
en gagnant en organisant ses
compétitions il assure son existence une
sorte d'assurance vie par rapport aux
appétits saoudiens et iraniens qui ont
été une concurrence dans la région de
cousins entre les Émirats arabes unis et
le Qatar puisque normalement les
Américains auraient voulu que le Qatar
fasse partie de la Fédération donc il
mise sur le sport en disant le sport
c'est populaire alors ils avaient pas
calculé que ça allait aussi attirer
beaucoup d'ennuis que la visibilité elle
était à double tranchant mais finalement
quand même il doit se dire finalement
quand même au total maintenant tout le
monde nous connaît et notre existence
elle est plus assurée un pays qui
organise la Coupe du monde n'est pas
annexé par son voisin et donc c'est et
puis l'objectif il est quand même
politique Mbappé ça vaut moins cher
qu'un rafale donc en fait on peut quand
même faire des choses comme ça et voilà
ils existent et c'est bon et après
effectivement il y a les aspects plus
critiquables mais bon Stéphane fort on
parlait de cette opinion publique qui a
quand même changé aujourd'hui la
résonance est différente que ça soit
avec les ONG mais les médias aussi et
puis et peut-être la conscience cette
opinion elle est peut-être différente il
y a même il y a 12 ans au moment où le
Qatar avait été choisi en tout cas pour
rebondir sur les propos de Pascal
Boniface ils ont ils ont acheté Mbappé
et les rafales comme ça au moins ils
sont sûrs
et ça c'est l'un des aspects qu'on a mis
en lumière dans notre enquête c'est à
dire que le l'obtention de la Coupe du
Monde et Le sans doute le coup de pouce
de Nicolas Sarkozy pour que le 14
obtiennent cette Coupe du Monde c'est
fait en échange d'une promesse d'achat
de Rafale un contrat énorme de milliards
d'euros et ça on a trouvé les documents
de l'Elysée qui en attestent la vente de
Rafale et la vente de de batterie de
missiles entiers aérien était au menu du
déjeuner et ce jour-là oui mais ce
fameux
ils en ont parlé non mais ça c'est
normal je veux dire quand vous avez moi
se rencontrent on met sur un papier la
liste des sujets qu'ils doivent aborder
et la vente des rafales la France depuis
longtemps en plus c'est c'est Hollande
quand la profité
le détail de la note diplomatique et
donc j'ai exactement en fait le
calendrier et les Qataris avaient essayé
au mois de juillet les rafales et
l'Élysée attendait une réponse
importante au mois de janvier donc juste
après la désignation du Qatar comme
payer organisateur de la Coupe du monde
donc évidemment que cet enjeu était
prégnant il était
Sarkozy il aurait acheté avant 2012 pour
assurer sa réélection plutôt que pour
conforter Hollande puisque en fait on
n'a pas vendu de ravale sous Sarkozy
tous les rafales ont évolues sous
Hollande donc il a travaillé pour le
droit de Prusse dans ces cas-là bah
[Musique]
était pendant toutes ces années la
vitrine on va dire de ce que préparait
le
Qatar dans son pays pour la Coupe du
monde alors évidemment ce qui apparaît
incroyable c'est que l'audience ça va
être 5 milliards de personnes dans le
monde c'est ce que j'ai lu moi cette
coupe du monde sont qui vont
c'est-à-dire c'est plus de la moitié du
Maïté non mais c'est donc c'est
exceptionnel enfin il y a que le
football il y a que la Coupe du monde
va connaître Mbappé et même si vie au
Galapagos etc c'est vraiment grâce à la
télévision qui a fait un stade au KPC
d'accueil universel tout le monde suit
le football c'est simple à comprendre on
peut y jouer partout donc évidemment
aucun sport ne fait de suscite autant
d'enthousiasme et aucun aucune activité
ne se situe autonociation que le sport
donc c'est vraiment le phénomène de la
globalisation de football voilà mais du
coup on se demande est-ce qu'il faut pas
de l'éthique est-ce qu'il faut pas une
forme de morale parce que ça touche
autant de monde est-ce que c'est pas le
moment justement de parler aussi
d'éthique en fait justement non
seulement on peut parler d'éthique on
peut parler de capacité d'influence le
football qui a autant de résonances qui
rentrent dans tous les foyers on peut
aussi se dire que c'est un moyen de
transmettre des messages et de parler on
parlait des joueurs nous on a interpellé
le jour de l'équipe de France on leur a
dit prenez la parole vous avez de
l'influence des jeunes vous écoutent
aujourd'hui que que les jeunes
aujourd'hui en France sachent que le
Qatar c'est le pays où la Coupe du Monde
c'est une chose mais qui sache aussi que
le Qatar c'est un pays où il y a eu un
certain nombre de violation de droits
humains qui ont été commises et qu'on
leur demande des comptes et que la FIFA
doit être regardée sur ce sujet là c'est
aussi important c'est aussi des messages
qu'on passe pour pour que la question du
sport soit pas complètement déconnectée
de ces sujets là qui touchent tout le
monde avec un tel impact c'est vrai
qu'on se demande est-ce qu'il faut pas
plus de contrôle est-ce qu'il faudrait
que ça soit un peu plus clean parce
qu'elle Boniface quand on touche
sociale les instances sportives
effectivement et qui est disons que du
fait de la pression des ONG des opinions
publiques et de certains gouvernements
elle sera de plus en plus forte le CIO a
quand même changé par rapport à la façon
dont il appliquait les règles la FIFA
est à la bourre assez clair que ils sont
un petit peu en retard par rapport à
cela l'UEFA a changé sous l'impulsion de
Michel Platini moi je regrette que
Monsieur patine soit pas la tête de la
FIFA parce que il y aurait beaucoup plus
de prise de conscience il a souvent pris
des positions pour aider des équipes à
avoir des matériels qui a pas de blocage
etc bon mais en tous les cas il y a un
système qui est compliqué
dans un système où la visibilité du
sport lui donne des obligations qu'il
n'assument pas encore tout à fait et que
donc il y a un retard entre les
obligations que le sport a comme fait
social total et sa visibilité la
visibilité a cru de façon plus rapide on
est plus seulement dans du sport
on se souvient qu'avant la Coupe du
Monde du Brésil il y avait eu beaucoup
de manifestations beaucoup de
protestations où les Brésiliens se
disaient mais nous nos hôpitaux ils sont
dans un mauvais état et puis on va les
on va en faire certains qui seront bien
uniquement parce qu'il y a la Coupe du
monde donc il y avait eu aussi des
demandes et des revendications en ce
moment-là il y avait certains chantiers
de de stade qui avait été retardé à
cause de conditions écologiques enfin on
se souvient qu'il y avait aussi alors là
comme c'était dans une démocratie
effectivement c'était dans un contexte
totalement différent
de toute façon au départ il y avait 12
villes qui avait été désignées et
c'était 12 villes pour faire plaisir à
12 gouvernants et ensuite on était
revenu à 10 la FIFA avait demandé que ce
soit 8 bon il y avait eu des
négociations donc il y a toujours de
toute façon le politique qui qui
intervient dans le choix quand le pays
est organisateur de toute Nathalie
Godard en tout cas vous amenez cette
international vous ne boycotez pas vous
n'appelez pas au boycott pourquoi alors
on appelle pas au boycott parce qu'on
fait depuis le début on a notre rôle
c'était documenté de faire la lumière
sur la situation des droits humains au
Qatar et qu'on a plutôt essayé
d'utiliser ce moyen là pour faire
pression sur le Qatar pour mettre la
lumière et que d'appeler au boycott
n'allait pas plus nous aider à faire la
lumière sur le sur la situation là on a
on a pu obtenir justement des avancées
sans appeler au boycottes et pas pour
autant efficace en fait on n'a pas de on
ne dit pas qu'il faut pas le faire les
organisations qui appellent au boycott
c'est leur moyen d'action donc c'est un
autre moyen d'action qu'on a choisi
vraiment impeccable parce que vous vous
occupez l'homme partout et vous
sélectionnez pas moi j'entends des gens
qui tout d'un coup sont soucieux du sang
et travailleur immigré au Qatar qui sont
moins soucieux du sort et travailleur
immigré en France ou ailleurs donc il y
a quand même il y a beaucoup
d'hypocrisie chez certains qui appellent
au boycott oh mais c'est pas comparable
je me suis rendu moi j'ai passé 15 jours
dans les camps de travail au Qatar et
j'ai documenté la manière dont ils
vivent c'est pas comparable avec la
France en France un travailleur immigré
même sans papiers il peut sortir boire
un verre il peut se divertir il peut
aller au cinéma il peut flirter avec une
femme il peut vivre en fait au-delà de
son travail ce qui n'est pas du tout le
cas au Qatar au Qatar c'est ok tu
travailles 12 heures dans la journée on
te ramène en bus au fin fond de la zone
industrielle qui est enclavé dans une
chambre infestée de cafard où il n'y a
rien à faire mais rien il y a
strictement rien à faire si ce n'est
allé voir de l'alcool frolater le soir
sur un terrain vague je veux dire c'est
vraiment pas comparable et sur le boycot
et ce qui se passe en France sur le
boycott moi je pense qu'il faut pas
culpabiliser
je pense qu'on est déjà dans une période
qui est quand même stressante qui
angoissante au niveau mondial je pense
qu'il faut pas culpabiliser les gens
apportons leur toutes les informations
nécessaires et qu'il fasse leur choix on
leur a mis conscience je crois surtout
que il y aurait dû avoir une vraie
mobilisation au moment de la désignation
du Qatar et de beaucoup plus anticiper
ou critiqué à ce moment-là voir de
dessaisir le payeur organisateur mais là
on est au moment où on va se dérouler
l'événement et je pense que c'est trop
tard c'est trop tard pour pour le
boycott et puis c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure pour l'Argentine par
exemple ça peut aussi justement apporter
un éclairage et servir d'une façon plus
positive
qu'est-ce qui va se passer après la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar
les travailleurs migrants que j'ai le
temps me disent qu'est-ce qui va se
passer une fois que les projecteurs
seront étant une fois que les médias ne
parlons plus de nous en fait il faudra
que l'eau it reste garde son bureau et
comme on continue à faire son boulot que
les âgées continuent à surveiller de
continuer de travailler enfin le
mouvement international les chercheurs
qui travaillent sur le cadre vont
continuer après c'est vrai qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de lumière énormément
d'articles de presse de médias et de
reportages en particulier sur celle là
en France jamais et on espère que il y
aura une documentation qui va continuer
parce qu'en fait si il y a des
régulations quand évolué mais qui ne
sont pas appliquées il faut il faut
continuer la pression pour que ce soit
le cas et le fond d'indemnisation si on
n'a pas de réponse maintenant on veut
l'avoir après et on lâchera pas pour
avoir cette réponse là mais ça faut que
ça change dans la designation de ces
pays haute
c'est ça
encore on ne peut pas réserver des coups
du Monde des Jeux Olympiques uniquement
dans les pays occidentaux l'Occident a
perdu le monopole de la puissance mais
est-ce qu'on pourra ajouter des critères
le critère écologique par exemple pour
enlever le sol
logique il est de plus en plus présent
il était inexistant 2010 il a paru en
cours de route maintenant on pourra plus
faire alors bon il y a l'airby C8 et les
Jeux asiatiques divers ça c'est une
aberration et enfin
on pourra pas l'empêcher à l'avenir non
plus non mais en fait disons que les les
gens qui veulent faire du sport washi en
disant je prends une compétition comme
ça on parlera le moins bien ils ont
compris maintenant qu'on parle de toi en
bien mais aussi on parle de toi en mal
et donc ils feront la balance entre les
deux vous pensez il faudrait des
critères supplémentaires certainement je
pense que ces dictées justement par
toutes les polémiques qui qui entourent
par exemple cette compétition
vraisemblablement alors la prochaine
elle aura lieu aux Etats-Unis Mexique et
Canada donc ça sera pas du tout le même
contexte et on se posera sur d'autres
pas les mêmes questions on se pose
peut-être beaucoup des questions sur
l'écologie voilà exactement sur les sur
les les trajets sur les avions sur tout
ce qui pourra être
occasionné par les distances énormes
finalement de l'Amérique du Nord bon
allez pronostics parce qu'il nous reste
cinq petites minutes à ni alors la
France déjà est-ce qu'elle peut gagner
alors écoutez les statistiques disent
que c'est très difficile de conserver
son titre quand on est champion du monde
parfois même on perd le premier match
parfois même on sort au premier tour et
c'est ce que nous ont montré les
dernières éditions l'Allemagne la France
l'Espagne en 2014 donc c'est aussi bien
de finalement de découvrir des nouveaux
champions maintenant je pense que
on y a Kylian Mbappé il y a sans doute
Karim Benzema même si on connaît pas
encore trop l'état physique dans lequel
il est et puis il y a beaucoup
d'incertitudes mais il y a Didier
Deschamps qui est l'artisan de cette de
cette équipe et qui finalement est quand
même quelqu'un d'extraordinaire qui a
été champion en tant que joueur et en
tant que en tant que sélectionneur après
on a évidemment d'autres équipes qui
espèrent bien faire l'histoire et je
pense l'Argentine peut-être le Brésil a
pu une équipe africaine le Brésil est
toujours il est le seul à avoir cinq
Coupes du monde et il est toujours parmi
les favoris donc avec ce serait possible
parce que c'est légal peut-être c'est
encore un peu juste
finalement le Sénégal joue sans Sadio
Mané alors ils ont beaucoup d'autres
joueurs il était pas seul sur le terrain
quand ils ont été sacrés champion
d'Afrique donc ça peut être possible
mais ça sera difficile mais pourquoi pas
toute façon c'est aussi ça je pense la
magie du football c'est à dire que à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui alors c'est sûr
que en plus rien n'est normal dans cette
compétition on va dire la temporalité
l'organisation et tout ça ben on ne sait
pas parce qu'à Boniface les Bleus
peuvent-ils gagnés rapidement
c'est la certitude du sport il y a cinq
ou six équipes qui sont favorites est-ce
qu'il y aura une surprise pour l'instant
à part l'Espagne en 2010 il y a pas de
surprise c'est toujours les pays qui ont
déjà gagné la Coupe du Monde qui a gagné
la liste bon est-ce que les Pays-Bas
vont y enfin arriver sur une surprise
africaine bon bah écoutez on verra
réponse au 18 décembre
l'équipe de France je sais pas parce
qu'il y a quand même une ambiance en ce
moment au sein de la Fédération
française de football qui interpelle je
sais pas si vous avez vu les articles de
presse récemment sur la sur la
gouvernance au sein de la FFF la guerre
entre les différents clans etc je me
demande si cette ambiance un petit peu
pesante
va influer sur le moral du groupe là-bas
je me demande Annie pardon Nathalie
pardon alors moi je vais faire un vrai
Joker sur les yeux
pronostics on est vraiment là pour le
coup dans le pur sport et plus dans le
la politique ou le droit humain donc je
vais pas m'aventurer pas vous pourrez de
temps en temps regarder la télévision
mais c'est plus pour pas forcément on va
dire dans mon dans mon champ d'intérêt
mais je dis pas je ne suis pas contre le
fait de regarder le match pour ceux qui
aiment ça d'avoir été avec nous Nathalie
Godard pardon vous avez rappelé Annie
trois fois Annie Gasnier était avec nous
merci à vous merci Pascal Boniface et
puis merci beaucoup pierre Stéphane fort
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivi
vous restez avec nous sur France 24